well that's obvious because they
contradict each other what contradicts
each other the Bible says that Jesus is
God and very good so what does that mean
that means they're contradictory that
means which concludes that what I'm not
reaching the same conclusion that you
have the conclusion that I reached is
that the the gospel that you have the
New Testament isn't the same that was
revealed to there someone evidence just
because it contradicts what the Quran
says wait listen is religion based
solely on evidence faith is based on
evidence how not fully not fully faith
is this well this is what the Bible says
the Bible says that faith is the
substance of things hoped for the
evidence of Things Not Seen so the
things that you don't you haven't seen
but there's evidence for it and you
trust in that that's what faith is
that's what the Bible says faith is it's
not blind yo welcome back how are you
today mate I'm good how are you I'm fine
thank you good so your subject is the in
right okay well the inil is the book
that Allah subhana T revealed to Jesus
did you do some research on Allah not
being able to have sons without a wife
oh yeah I actually sent you a counter
argument on DM I wanted to go back up
but didn't have the time okay what's the
argum okay oh my God I forgot it I
forgot it we do it next time all right
so what the the inil is the book that
was revealed to yeah but what is that
though it's a revelation from God it was
like words not actual physical book it's
different from the gospels that we have
today in the
Bible what how is it different from the
gospels that we have today well because
it supposedly teaches The Message of
Islam the message of monotheism and
legislations that are relatively close
to Islam like not eating pork not eating
not drinking wine for example where
where do you get this idea that the inil
taught not to eat pork because the Quran
simply says it doesn't that pork meat
isn't allowed it's Haram where does that
say that it's Haram for Jesus or that
Jesus came teaching that pork is Haram
well wasn't it allow fortical priests
where do you get this where do you get
this idea of levitical priests it wasn't
for them though was it where do you get
this idea about levitical priests I read
somewhere in the Old Testament so in the
so the Old Testament is that like the
Torah I mean it has some truths in it
but it's not the actual Torah that was
revealed to Moses okay so so don't don't
refer to a a corrupted book please my
bad so I'll ask again how do you know
that it was forbidden for Jesus to eat
pork or that he taught not to eat pork I
mean legislations do not different like
different a lot from one another so I
thought was for the prophet Muhammad it
wasn't allowed for other prophets that's
not true at all the Quran literally says
Jesus made lawful things that were
forbidden there are some things but
there are some things that cannot change
so how do you know that he didn't change
the law of eating pork how do you know
that in Theo it was not allowed to eat
pork because Islam teaches that anything
that harms the body is not allowed and
po the body that's not true mine
alcohol was once allowed in the Quran
right in small quantities like it was a
start of as progressive revelation so in
small quantities it doesn't say small
quantities in the Quran what it doesn't
say it doesn't say small quantities of
alcohol is allowed in I get I get that
from was from the scholars but the Quran
doesn't say that it doesn't but that's
what the what the scholars deduct after
reading the Quran they interpret it so
the Quran doesn't say that so here we
arguing where do you get it from that
pork was not a allow in the because
Jesus changed some of the laws Chang how
do you know according to the Quran that
the laws that were changed are the same
as the in Islam I'm showing you bro you
said that the laws that the legislation
doesn't change from Prophet to Prophet
that's what you said they changed but
not a lot not a lot not like a huge
difference okay good so how do you know
that the legislation on pork was
forbidden in the in theil or not forbid
in the well first of all we go back to
verse 48 we can judge the previous
scriptures by the Quran it doesn't say
just the previous scriptures by the
Quran it says that it's a supreme
authority it's a Criterion it's a foran
it doesn't say it's a Criterion it says
a guardian foran is not it doesn't foran
is not in that in that verse it's that's
what it implicates that's the context oh
no that's not what it
implicates you telling me how to
interpret the Quran brother yes you
don't know how to do it every time I
talk to you about the Quran you don't
know how to interpret it brother again I
take my interpretation from Scholars I
do not take it from my own wi so do I
I'm taking it from Scholars and your
Scholars your Scholars SCH muhamad means
witness and guardian not okay Guardian
what does it mean a guardian so it's not
a judge it's not it doesn't judge the
scriptures the Quran judges the people
it says judge between them by it says a
guardi
over so again how do you know that pork
was not allowed in the in or that it was
forbidden in theil how do you know what
laws were in theil at all well I already
told you that we the Quran for that I'm
I cannot make sure 100% but I as I told
you already so the Quran doesn't tell
you right yeah so then you can't rely on
the Quran because it doesn't tell you so
don't assert things that you you're not
even your Quran doesn't say what did I
say all right let's go back to square
one okay how is the NG different from
the gospel that I have today well do you
have any first century man manuscript
how do you know that theil is written in
the first century it isn't there isn't
any first centur manuscript okay so then
that should be out the window so it
wasn't a first century manuscript so
that's irrelevant you don't have to do
you what does that have to do with theil
you just said theil is not a first
century manuscript we're talking 100
years the oldest go ahead you you
yourself said the angil was not written
in the first century yeah it wasn't it
wasn't written okay so then why are you
asking me do I have a first century
manuscript if I like it matters theil
was not written in the first century so
that's that's irrelevant if I don't if I
don't have a first century manuscript of
my gospel then that matches theil that's
not written in the first century
according to you I'm not talking about
theil that was revealed to Esa I asked
what was what differ the New Testament
oh so is there a different in yeah the
New Testament is different from the inel
the gospel so the the New Testament is a
inel but it's just different it's like a
book ascribed to Allah but it's not the
inil that Allah revealed is the New
Testament the or not no okay so I'll ask
again go ahead what the difference
between the inil and the gospel that I
have the gospel that you have okay well
well from the Quran I can tell you that
the gospel you have right now is written
by people that ascribed to Allah but
theil was revealed by Allah himself wait
is written by people that what ascribed
it to Allah attributed to Allah and
theil was revealed by Allah to ASA who
wrote it who wrote it's probably the
disciples or ASA himself because he oh
the disciples wrote the in I cannot make
sure I don't not know let me give give
me a likely answer it's either Isa or
the disciples but I'm guessing it's the
disciples because they heard them from
him and stuff you know let's go with
that the disciples wrote the NG the
disciples wrote the Gospel that I have
so it looks like we're still in the same
boat no the goel you have have Anonymous
writers huh the the the gospel that you
have the New Testament has Anonymous
writers who wrote the NGO which which
disciples wrote the NGO I clearly do not
know so they're anonymous they're both
Anonymous yeah looks like we're in the
same boat again so the was written by
the disciples the gospel was written by
the disciples the gospel has Anonymous
authors theil has Anonymous authors so
far what's the difference between theil
and my gospel as I already told you the
was revealed to ISA the gospel were
attributed to Allah but hold on when you
say revealed to Jesus how so like what's
Jesus walking around with the New
Testament in his hands was he walking
around with what with an inil in his
hands a new testament was he walking
around with an inil in his hands no it
was words like the Quran okay so look
we're good we we still in the same boat
Jesus wasn't walking around with a new
testament in his hands Jesus wasn't
walking around with an inil in his hands
we in the same boat what's the
difference the New Testament supposedly
was written by people who heard from Esa
same right so what's the difference was
revealed TOA it was words from an angel
an angel Revelations where dides your
Quran say an angel revealed the angel to
Jesus we know Angel Gabriel revealed all
the revelations to all Prophets Show me
where it says the angel Gabriel revealed
the angel to Jesus well the Quran
doesn't Clearly say that but that's the
deduction of the scholars so where are
you getting it from deduction of the
scholars who who who yeah I mean that's
what I read but I don't remember who
exactly you can't the amount of bid that
you have done in this conversation is
astounding just make it St how how
you're saying things that your Quran
doesn't say you're saying things that's
nowhere in your Quran not even verbatim
not hint to that not alluded to none of
this is in your Quran that the angel
Gabriel revealed the inil to Jesus
that's crazy I know that it doesn't but
I before my bad so let's go over this
again Jesus was not walking around with
the New Testament in his hands he also
wasn't walking around with an inil in
his hands yes the gospel and theil were
written by his disciples you said that
the gospel writers are Anonymous so are
the writers of theel they are Anonymous
if we go with your viw we're in the same
boat what is the difference between the
inil and the gospel that I have the
difference well I cannot clearly tell
you but it has it definitely has a
different message ah all right so so I
mean you kind of you kind of got there
but then you you got to the Finish Line
closely but then you you went back right
in front of the C Finish Line because
when you say that you can't clearly tell
me the difference means that you can't
tell me that what I have is not the in
because it sounds like what we have we
believe in the same thing that's what it
sounds like to me but when you say oh
well the message in the inil is
different than the message that's in the
gospel show me that have wait have you
read the inil the New Testament no the
inil oh is oh is the new test the inil
no I'm just asking what you're referring
to exactly I mean let me know I mean if
I say inil
what is the New Testament in Gil I'll go
with that is the new no okay you're
smart you're smart you feel me Chef
logic baby so so when you say so yeah
have you ever read the no have you ever
seen it seen it no have you ever touched
it no have you ever smelled it what are
these questions no okay so how do you
know that the message of being that
you've never read touched smelt tasted
been around seen is different in the
message that I have in my gospel how do
you know Faith what can I tell you it's
Faith but we can also Point some stuff
like the the not having give me a second
bro you answer that quickly I didn't
expect you to
say so you have a blind
faith just yeah go ahead and unmute when
it's over but guys our frd is here he
has a blind faith in this imaginative
Ino that he's never seen never touched
never read never tasted never smelt
never been around nothing that this
imaginary inel who looks like there's no
clear difference between this inel and
my gospel that it has a different
message than what my gospel than what's
in my gospel Blind Faith is the Crux and
the foundation of Islam that's the point
the point is is that my Muslim friends
who I love and I care about my Muslim
guests who come up here and engage with
me have no basis or substance to what
they say and everything that they're
saying is resting on Blind Faith who how
could you be comfortable with that
exactly walking in darkness how could
you be comfortable chilling in Blind
Faith how I couldn't do it myself I
couldn't are you asking me or no I was
just I was just talking to the audience
until you got back but you're back still
done they give me like two more minutes
or three okay okay I I can entertain
them I can entertain the crowd I
couldn't be okay with that go I could
not be okay with resting and sitting and
chilling in our Blind Faith standing on
something that I that's that's air
Walking on Air Walking on Air man you
know don't say no one could he he's
doing it but it's not just him it's all
the people that came up even the guy
before was it the guy before him Ibrahim
before him admitted that he's walking in
Blind Faith he said exactly I said so
you're just trusting all you're resting
on Blind Faith with all this and he said
exactly he said exactly you it's not the
story of Blind Faith because I've seen
some stuff within my two eyes and I
found peace in Islam it's not like it's
completely blind faith but when it comes
to Christianity other religions then yes
you can say so so do Mormons I just had
a Mormon early uh yesterday who said the
same thing you said that he prayed about
it prayed about Mormonism prayed about
Joseph Smith and realized it was the
truth with his own experience a Mormon
says the same thing okay but then that
that wouldn't make it Blind Faith
because they they've seen some stuff
that there is Blind Faith how because
you're not resting and trusting in
actual evidence it's not actual evidence
well how can you make sure that the
gospels or the New Testament that you
have was the one that the disciples
wrote because we have traditions and
manuscripts that all agree for 2,000
years and Matthew wrote Matthew Luke
wrote Luke John wrote John Mark wrote
Mark but then I ask you the the
manuscripts 90% of them after when do
they come who cares after the seventh
century by way you want to know why this
is this is irrelevant why because if you
are doubting the authorship of the New
Testament you also have doubts about the
authorship of yel but you still believe
in it well yeah as I told you it's Faith
right so why don't you have that same
faith in the gospel that I have yeah I'm
basic I'm showing you that you have
based on your position you have
absolutely no reason to reject the
gospel that I have as the inel it's the
same thing you believe in what I have
well then again when when you read the
Quran I read it multiple times like I
finished it multiple times through my my
life I saw some miracles in it I saw
some prophecies come true I saw
prophecies from the prophet Muhammad
come true I saw a lot of stuff in it
that make me believe in Islam it's not
like completely blind faith but when it
comes to other religions yes you can say
so because we don't have evidence of
previous books we don't have evidence of
previous books yes wait so we don't have
evidence that there was a gospel in the
6th Century that the Christians were
following during the time of Muhammad
what no that's not what I'm talking
about I'm talking about the time of time
of oh you're saying that in these books
we don't have evidence that they're like
true or the word of God that's what
you're saying we don't have evidence
that they even existed we don't have
proof that the I I know I know we don't
we we don't have proof that Jesus
actually existed not Jesus the books
that if Jesus is if Jesus your Quran
says that Jesus came confirming the
Torah and the Torah you believe was
given to Moses right yes isn't that
evidence that Moses existed since Jesus
has what was passed down from Moses I
didn't say that I didn't don't believe
that they but I said that's evidence
right there what that's evidence that's
I didn't say that I don't believe that
they existed I just don't believe that
the books that you have today are the
original ones that was revealed to them
got it got it but it's not based on
anything see when when when everything
that we have says it is what it is says
this is the Torah that Moses wrote says
we have the PMS that David wrote says we
have the gospel that Jesus preached and
that his disciples wrote says that we
have the writings of Isaiah you can't
make 100% sure what what doubt what what
reason to doubt do you have well do you
have the actual manuscripts that Moses
wrote of course not that's too old yeah
but we have we have tradition but how
can you prove that that tradition was
reliable Jesus authentically Jesus said
it's reliable your Quran says it's
reliable your Quran quotes it but
brother it isn't talking about the
physical book yes your Quran quotes my
Bible did you know that yeah I know it
does but is talking about the words I'm
just I don't understand how is it that
your Quran can verbatim quote my Bible
but you still say that oh but we don't
have proof that that what you have is
what the Quran was talking about help me
understand that well that's obvious
because they contradict each other what
contradicts each other the the Bible
says that Jesus is God and very good so
what does that mean that means they're
contradictory that means qur concludes
that what I'm not reaching the same
conclusion that you have my mind doesn't
work like that but but but just answer
what what what's the conclusion that I
have off that the conclusion that I
reached is that the the gospel that you
have the New Testament isn't the same
that was revealed to someone evidence
just because it contradicts what the
Quran says wait listen is religion based
solely on evidence faith is based on
evidence how not fully not fully faith
is this well this is what the Bible says
the Bible says that faith is the
substance of things hoped for the
evidence of Things Not Seen so the
things that you don't you haven't seen
but there's evidence for it and you
trust in that that's what faith is
that's what the Bible says faith is it's
not blind so position when when you when
you like I'm just like please like I'm
I'm sure 700 of us we we really want to
know how you're okay how this makes
sense that because the Quran contradicts
the Bible when it says the Bible is true
then that means the Bible's changed that
wouldn't mean mean that it just means
that the Quran is false for
contradicting true books that's the
conclusion that you reached after
reading that's the L it's like this it's
like this look step one the Quran says
the Bible is true step two the Quran
contradicts the Bible step three if the
Quran contradicts the Bible which is
true then the Quran is false that's just
B that's just the basic syllogism bro
it's the basic steps in the argument
That's The Logical conclusion it's over
you see I I don't got to come up with
nothing special for that it's nothing
super intellectual it's not it's a super
boom boom boom simple Quran says Bible's
true Quran contradicts Bible therefore
Quran is false cuz it contradicts a true
book here's another one look look here's
another one Quran says Bible is true
Bible is corrupted Quran affirms a
corrupted book therefore Quran is false
you see either way it it doesn't work
that's why the Quran doesn't affirm the
book that you have with you it quotes it
it quotes it how where chapter 5: 45 It
quotes it what Allah has revealed there
in no bro no chapter 5 verse 4 let the
people of the Gospel judge by the that's
47 Hab that's 47 I'm talking about verse
45 see you know that I'm a shake and I'm
going to I'm going to guide you to the
right path man not the path that Allah
is on I'm going guard you to the right
path go ahead you don't have it in front
of you what you don't have it in front
of you the Quran no I'm not pure to
touch it you're not pure to touch it no
if you come to Christ you can touch it
whenever you want you'll be pure well I
understand your concerns but what can I
say what I can tell you what you can say
this religion is false man I'm out I
can't I can't sit and Blind Faith
anymore man what's the truth is Jesus
the truth if he is the truth Lord reveal
yourself to me show me yourself that's
what you can say but that's what I would
do okay let's go through this what does
the verse say all right so the verse
says sorry and we are named We ordained
therein the Torah for them now it's
about to quote it life for Life eye for
an eye nose for nose ear for an ear
tooth for tooth wounds for wounds equal
for equal okay that's Exodus chapter 21
it Lally quotes what I have quotes my
Bible yeah I already told you that
there's still some truths in your book
I'm not saying that it's completely
false but listen your Quran is saying
that what I have it's what it's talking
about
go ahead yeah it even quotes my Psalms I
feel like I showed you this before no I
didn't show you this stuff this is my
second time talking to you actually wow
is it you sound like another guy I spoke
to but in chapter 21 verse
105 It quotes my Psalms It quotes Psalm
37 what does it say about to show you
Habibi hold on it says and indeed we
have written in the psalm my righteous
servants shall inherit the land that's
Psalms 37: vers 29 you know that
actually strangth my faith right now
thank you that actually did oh my
God honestly what what oh my God they
actually did they don't know how so
because if the Quran says that he has
ordained that he is written that in
Psalms when the prophet was a literate
and they didn't know Hebrew Syriac Greek
how could how could the prophet know or
his companions they didn't know any of
these languages how did they know that
Allah has written that in the Psalms
because your Hadith say that the Jews
would recite to him the Torah in the old
Arabic Arabic no way does it say that
Zab nowhere does it say what it doesn't
nowh it doesn't say the Zab the T not
according to your some a lot of your
Scholars the Torah is the entire Old
Testament the entire Old Testament yeah
not just the Books of Moses some of them
refer to the Torah as the entire Old
Testament well can you quote the Hadith
about him reciting them reciting the
Torah in Arabic yep I could find it used
to hear this stuff all the time man
that's nothing special it's not a
miracle Island Girl these are some some
names Shan was inspired by the Bible
with a little twist what the hell Hamas
are terrorists okay buddy you guys have
the does anyone have the exact Hadith
but is it before all yes of course it is
I never quote weak Hadith you know a
Muslim tried to use a weak Hadith
against me once did he yeah not only did
he do that but he he tried to in his
screenshot he cut where it gives the
grade of the it was funny what is this
study this doesn't help me
quite
485 okay let's try that yeah open it
yeah they said 4485 the is not here to
confirm a Greek Roman inspired book yeah
I know
[Music]
that okay
yeah bukari
4485 okay
it's oh thank you Scott I see I see so
it says narrated Abu hrera the people of
the scripture used to recite the Torah
in Hebrew and they used to explain it in
Arabic to the Muslims on that Allah's
messenger said what did he say it said
do not believe the people of the
scripture or disbelieve them but say we
believe the Israelites law and yeah and
what is revealed to us that's funny but
it's good but yeah so Muhammad used to
hear all kinds of stuff in the Old
Testament but he said not to believe in
it nor disbelieve don't believe the
people or the people but say he say the
scripture or the people he says the
people he says do not believe the people
of the scripture or disbelieve them but
say we believe in Allah and what is
revealed to us so basically they were
untrust he didn't really trust them so
if he didn't really trust them that
doesn't mean that doesn't mean that he
actually took from them or C it from
them that that does mean that he took
for them because you see him taking from
he said that he doesn't trust them but
he doesn't believe nor disbelieve so he
takes what he likes puts his little
Islamic Twist on it put it in the Quran
what an Islamic twist but will you have
to prove that the verse you quot it
about a minute ago alliance with what
the Jews and the Christians said used to
recite I I I gave you Exodus chapter 21
it literally quotes Exodus 21 5:45
quotes Exodus 21 chter 21: 105 quotes
Psalm
39: 27 how how how does Muhammad know
this because he was around Jews he was
around War wara you know used to teach
him stuff War died before actually
witnessing but he still used to teach
him stuff nowhere does it say that
you're talking about 3 because he died
before even witnessing the prophet
claiming his Prophet yeah but he was
very close to wara did was he not but
wara used to travel a lot it's not like
he was with their Peninsula all the time
waraka and Muhammad were extremely close
according to what according to your
Hadith when he when he died Muhammad
went into depression I mean yeah because
he's the one who told him that it was an
angel that was revealed to him yeah if
wara is the one who's telling him about
his Revelation and all that kind of good
stuff come on man simple but again it
seems kind of compelling you know but I
don't know that's what it is man that's
what it is so look this this is this is
the thing you have the Quran literally
telling you look you won't have to be
stuck if you just let the Quran speak
for itself the Quran is telling you that
what I have is true it's really simple
It quotes it it tells us to follow it
and judge by it and even if Muhammad is
in doubt it says go ask the people
who've been reading the scripture before
you that's what Allah says to Muhammad
chap 10:94 if you're in doubt about
anything we revealed to you go and ask
the people who've been reading the book
before you it tells them can I ask you
question yeah you know Prophet I mean I
think his name is Jethro in the Bible or
something like that Prophet Prophet hood
you know these three prophets I don't
know h I don't know Jethro Shish je
Jethro okay and who else I don't
remember who H is exactly but I think is
meth yeah I don't know who that is these
no I actually tried searching for these
characters in The Bible but I couldn't
find them neither in the Bible nor the
talmud so I was wondering from where did
he get them right the city
of oh I know what you're talking the
Quran how references H yeah yeah isn't
mentioned anywhere in the previous
scripture yeah no Jethro is in the Bible
though Jethro is the father in-law of
Moses but his story isn't in the Bible
yeah he doesn't have a story in the
Bible but you know his encounter with
Moses and his daughter sabora his
daughter married Moses stuff like that
but as far as like his background and
stuff yeah no you don't really get you
know he's a priest you don't you don't
really get anything else okay what about
Hood and the Miracle with camel yeah no
that doesn't exist well my faith
actually kind kind of relies on them
right now because they're not mentioned
anywhere in the previous scriptures that
means that youran is making stuff up
that could possibly be it but is proven
to have been in history before the city
ofam the city of the people of AD the
people of AD yep so the place what what
is that place the people of AD what
place is that the city is
called Iran Iram Iram Iram let me i r m
IR M
okay so that place exists or used to
exist used to exist yeah okay and so
what like what like you're saying that
there this the Quran mentioning these
people gives you faith in the Quran yeah
because they're not mentioned anywhere
in the previous scripture nor in the T
mode nor in gospels circulating around
the second third Century but how does
that give you faith in it like how does
that prove the Quran true because it
mentions something that exists but isn't
found in previous scripture that doesn't
that doesn't mean that anybody else
didn't mention it well do you have I
have to look I have to look at what
you're talking about though I have to
look yeah Prophet H Prophet chai Prophet
okay these are three these are three
Arabic prophets by the way Arabic so
then one of them is not jeffro yeah
probably I I got I got that from Google
because it's not trustworthy I's see
let's see all right well I mean is is he
had the zamzam well as a miracle too
it's not mentioned anywhere too that's
cuz that never happened what that's cuz
the zamzam well as of myth never
happened never happened yeah well how is
it in Saud Arabia right now you're
saying that ishma did that yeah it was
his Miracle yeah you know there's also a
a a cabba right in Mecca that is said to
have come down from the heavens it's not
the a stone it was a stone actually not
not the ca the stone my bad Stone came
down from heaven y I mean Iron came down
from heaven it's not that big of a deal
a meteorite so so the stone the stone is
a meteorite no but like if iron can come
down iron iron came down in a meteorite
what what proves that Stones Can't well
no they can so but you're saying it's
not an meteorite so I can't make sure
okay so the stone is a medor right that
you guys deem as holy it's also said in
I think it's in I I'll have to double
check don't quote me but I remember
looking at it I'll double check this
that uh it used to be white right but
you know it it absorbed the sins of the
people is that correct it's it didn't
absorb it became black over time because
the sins of the people right absorb it
didn't it doesn't say it absorbed it
okay okay okay well you know what I mean
thank you for correcting me but yeah
that that's that's some people telling
me that I'm being fooled by Zam but
actually scientific researches saw that
it's 100% pure even though it's been
there for thousands in of years that
ain't got nothing to do with is okay but
what do you think about the preservation
of the Quran what do you mean by
preservation because Allah in the Quran
said indeed we have sent down the and
indeed we are the ones preserving it
okay let's talk about what the I always
have a problem pronouncing that word
yeah can we just say reminder yeah
reminder okay reminder okay so it say
says that we have sent down the reminder
and we are its protector yep the Quran
says that the Torah is the reminder was
at some point yeah the Quran also says
that the inil is the reminder it calls
us the people of the
reminder mhm are you sure that's
referring to you yeah it tells the
support that point of view yes you go to
there yeah it's chapter
16:43 16:43 let me just PA to go how
much time you got what how much time do
you have you said you have to go pray 10
minutes approximately that's good enough
it's like 4:00 a.m. right now 4000 like
IO you doing up this late I mean I'm
free it's vacation okay that's good
tomorrow is J too I have congregation
prayer you know okay okay okay I
sometimes leave the prayer too I'll pray
for you bro what I said I'll pray for
you pray for me yeah I'll pray for you
thank you appreciate it so chapter 16:43
it says we sent not any before you
except men to whom we revealed right so
talking about Muhammad right we Ain sent
no nobody before you except who we
revealed y then it says ask the people
of the reminder you know not okay maybe
that's why bukari 4458 happened or eight
I don't remember this that's probably be
why but so do you see how it calls the
Jews and the Christians the people of
the reminder yeah but in in the context
of the of the reminder in the Quran it
talks about the Quran it also talks
about previous prophets too in the next
verse what affirms that view the context
when we go to chapter 15 verse 9 10 and
11 it talks about prophets previous
prophets before the Quran but do you
have any arguments against the
preservation of the Quran well my
argument right now is that this verse
that you think is talking about
preservation the Quran is actually
preservation of all of Allah's
scriptures the Quran the Torah and the
gospel well the T say is specifically
talking about the Quran in this context
of course they do I disagree with them
you disagree with them I disagree with a
lot of the tough that's outrageous no
it's not if debate him on Jesus being
the word of God you w't win you won't
win I'll destroy him n yeah because he
he explicitly goes against the Quran the
Quran the Quran says Jesus is the him
too the Quran says
to but the Quran says that Jesus is the
word of Allah it says he is his word
right if I comes in his tops and says
Jesus isn't the word of Allah he is made
by word of Allah yes it says that so the
Quran doesn't say that so I will
use the verse I will destroy if I'd
destroy him but anyway so when you say
preservation let like skip to the when
you say preservation do you mean that
the Quran it has been the same ever
since from the beginning from the time
of Muhammad all the way until now
there's no differences no changes it's
letter for letter word for word the
exact same yep all right so and if there
was any difference with would that
destroy the Quran saying that it
protects the Quran that Allah okay I'm
confident on this topic okay so remember
what you just said you just that if
there were any differences if there are
any differences then it would destroy
the Quran statement that Allah has
protected the Quran and that would mean
that the Quran is false yep okay you
read Arabic yes I know okay good all
right but you got to understand that
there's abrogation and there's that's
what we're going to talk about not ABG
we're going to talk about verses that
are the same verse that are different
okay you know theith that says the Quran
was revealed in seven accents seven
dialects yeah yeah well the dialects
have different words to give the vers
deeper meanings but they were revealed
simultaneously to the prophet all right
so I'll ask again because it sounds like
changing your position is there is there
any differences in the Quran what are
there any differences in the Quran
between the sure well yeah there are
some differences so how many qurans are
there well it was originally revealed in
seven accents then direct from these
seven accents readings which are 10 and
from these readings on these accents we
have multiple readings depending on the
dialect of the location so how many
qurans are there one huh one it sounds
like you said 10 or seven 10 readings of
the same Quran of the same Quran yep how
is it the same Quran if they defer in
places and I mean really differ really
differ yeah where like where like one
one like in the same verse one Quran
will be talking about Muhammad and the
other Quran will be talking about Allah
that that wait wait a minute I mean look
I already told you the some the verse is
sometimes different to give the verse a
deeper meaning so how is that the same
thing those will be different then right
yeah tot it have some differences
between the that would be a different
different Kuran unless you're saying
that like there's but understand point
that they were revealed simultaneously
the Quran has a multi like multiat like
type of nature yep okay so what if they
contradict each other you say like I
wonder and he wonders do you you
consider that a contradiction well no I
told you each has a meaning of its own
right so Allah wonders in one Quran
Muhammad wonders in that same verse in
another Quran and that's we're good yeah
I told you the the words different
different from one to another sometimes
I can give you examples myself I got you
I got you what about the ones that
contradict what do you consider a
contradiction a cannot be non a in the
same the same time in the same sense so
let's say for example example I one one
statement says I have one pin in my hand
the other statement in that same verse
talking about the same event same time
says I have two pins in my hand that'll
be a contradiction right can you point a
reference no but I'm going to say like
that would be an example of a
contradiction right yeah okay possibly
yeah got you I don't understand so one
example I will show is you probably know
about this one chapter 2: 84 where it
talks about what you do or what you can
do to make up for a day that you miss a
fasting did you feed a poor person you
familiar with that verse okay and the HS
it's singular all you need to do to
purify yourself for missing a fast day
is feed a poor person okay in the house
in the house in the colon it says what
you have to do to make up for a fast day
is feed poor people well so it's plural
sometimes singular words can come in
context of plural well no not this cuz
this we're talking about purification
what am I if I just Fe feed one poor
person am I good or do I have to feed
more than one poor person to be good can
you like how can I say this the words
the Arabic words can you like I'll show
it to you and let you I I forgot exactly
what the Arabic word is but I'll show it
to you so you can you can some dud said
it has historical errors I can give it
like six more minutes yep okay okay can
you see this clearly
[Music]
okay this is awesome okay and what
what's the word that we're looking at
that says a poor person I gu a m okay
yeah that's the word okay so now I'm
going to go down to I think this is
colum and same with war has the same
thing but so here it is is this the word
right here yeah which is poor people
right so this one says that in order
basically to make up for missing fasting
missing a fast day you have to feed poor
people while this says all you need to
do is feed a poor person to make up for
that day you missed well I've heard the
explanation of that verse specifically
but I don't clearly remember it but it
has a counter argument okay I I'll be
I'll be waiting for it for the next time
you come like for for me like you
understand the the issue is like M and
masak one is singular one is plural yeah
I know that and but like see the problem
is is that this is telling me what would
purify me if I miss a fast day so if I
do any if I do this wrong then I'm not
good you know so that has to do with you
know purification you know if I if if if
the truth is that all I need to do I'm
sorry if the truth is that I need to
feed poor people to make up for a fast
day then if I do what is according to
the hofs if I do this then I'm not good
I need to feed one more person you know
so it changes this you know so yeah well
I have the I had the explanation of that
before but like I don't clearly remember
it sorry no it's good it's good check
check that out tell me what you think
and we'll link up man and we'll talk
some more okay thanks for coming through
again man thanks to you all right peace
out peace out all right guys time for me
to go ahead and end it time for me to go
ahead and end it I love you guys I hope
you guys had a good time